thank you alejandro well i'm here with a
man that needs absolutely no
introduction the 13th world champion
gary kasparov gary first of all welcome
back to bucharest welcome back to the
studio what are your first impressions
of the tournament the organization and
we first saw you at the opening ceremony
tell us a bit about that
ah it's so spectacular it's uh i think
that's chess now is back to where it
belongs uh what i played world
championship matches uh
it's the level of respect and uh
uh and admiration that
the game has been lacking uh for a long
time i mean we know that's about saint
louis and the standards that have been
introduced by granchester in its place
of origin but you know having the
opening of the granchester of bucharest
in the chalcesque palace
the biggest building in europe and the
second one in the world of the pentagon
it's it's not just luxury it's it's not
just prestige it's just now it's it's um
it's it's for me it was a symbol of
returning chess
like history exactly to to
the mainstream and
and uh obviously the
recent tragic events in ukraine just uh
elevated you know just as uh more
interest and uh there are many
journalists uh obviously i wanted to
hear my opinion about the the
tragedy this in ukraine but again it's
it's all added to to do
to the tournament to the publicity of
the tournament and by the way i'm very
happy now i can just you know i i can
have the first glance at the games
because it's uh i'm i'm engaged in
never-ending interviews about russia and
ukraine the war and the
the response of the free world and it
goes on and on uh with probably every
major uh ukrainian tv radio station and
a newspaper
and now that's a it's a kind of a relief
now i can look at the chess board and
talk about the games that played by the
rules we'll definitely take a look at
the games in just a second but i do want
to ask you also played a simo with the
kids at the parliament i made three
moves how important is that for the kids
to get that feeling of playing with the
bachelor's players in history no look
it's it's
it's always about
happiness and and uh
a comfort of um the players uh who are
taking part of the cymbals it's not for
us to enjoy it uh for professionals but
it's it's an opportunity to i mean test
yourself against the best in the world
but also know to um
to get them just a moment of glory
because you make a picture you can shake
hands and uh i
i did first three three rounds you know
shook hands
uh i mean i know it's a bit now risky
these days but still it's as if if you
want an exhibition so forget about covet
so that's you have to you have to be
engaged that's also i think it's it's
been appreciated and also i have to say
that it's not a simon played in in a
cafe or or on a city square it was
the whole of of of george's palace it
says it's like size of a football field
yeah if not more
and and being there it's it's added to
the prestige of the game and
and i think all the players uh there
were kids there and some of the very
famous romanian athletes uh also among
them so they all you know felt that they
were part of history
a lot of this is due to the fact that
the super bad foundation has uh been
getting involved into the grand chester
big way tell us a bit about that and
what was the impact of this change look
um it's uh it's the the engagement was a
result of my trip to bucharest
uh in 2017 i was invited to do a
presentation uh for one of romanian
magazines and uh
one of the sponsors of the event was
sasha druggage a former servant chess
player who
stopped playing chess according to
sasha's because he looked at gary caspar
decided he couldn't be as successful and
moved into business yeah and now he's uh
he's you know giving back to chess to
this beloved game and um
we talked about uh about a possible
corporation so i invited me next year to
bucharest to do an event with superbed
super but it was just uh
rising as as a big force in romanian
business and actually european business
and uh um
and then
year after that on 2019 it was the first
super bad event
rapid and blitz
but i could already sense was appetite
to the war and it's not just now the
classic tournament in bucharest superbet
is involved and being a major sponsor in
all three eastern european tournaments
in uh as a group and in warsaw so now we
would say that you know this the um
graduate stories is balanced because we
have saint louis or chess capital
on uh
in the united states and now we have a
company uh that's fast fast growing
company that is willing to extend its
its um
participation in in all sorts of chess
projects from professional to
educational
i met here the minister of education of
romania and they're very impressed by
super bet's
uh uh willingness to uh invest heavily
in promoting chess in romanian
classrooms so
between saint louis and and superbit
i think
grand just tour has has a safe future
and it's not surprising that feed after
so many years of hesitations and and and
and uh
waffling decided uh to uh make
granchester part of the qualification
system so it's now it's it's solid
and and it has standards
that
yet remain
dreams for other chess events including
feed official competitions absolutely
and i know that we will have you uh in
future days as well to talk a bit more
about that but we do have some
incredible games today one especially is
this clash between ali reza against jan
nepam nyoshi what is your first take
when you see this position on the board
uh now we had a quick look you know just
about the game
that uh it started there was this very
slow uh um
opening
but i think it's a demonstration that
even if you play like you know the
bishop opening e45 bishop c4 it's about
the mood of the class whether they want
to play tough chess and it seems that
they do uh i was surprised just to find
out that many of the um
uh many of the moves that that okay
let's just
they played they played very fast so
that's the that means you know that
wasn't it was opening theory but then
our leaders have played h3 and g3 g4
looked
odd to me and and i think that
napoleon she missed a couple of really
good really you know uh good uh
opportunities so definitely this is the
move that i didn't like is is bishop
four here so i would definitely put
night my knight on the four and also i
think it was the it was earlier earlier
it wasn't even yeah yeah but he also
here here here with bishop d5 yeah
here knight four also knight of four and
you cannot take only four as we
discussed because bishop d5 i never seen
this and this is the first move that you
mentioned when you saw this yeah but
again this is that's the other night you
know that's yeah maybe goes from i know
just matches you know you can you want a
knight on this one yes yeah and and uh
and again bishop of four i think it is
the um
uh uh um
ali rozad did well i'm not sure that
queen h you know queen h4
i know that's it
it seems like he's losing some speed
right black that is allowing white cast
and also i'm not maybe against this is
maybe bishop take this three was was the
only only option
but it's difficult to give but
you just played bishop f4
yeah exactly but after this queen of d1
looks to me that white is
i wouldn't say winning but it's just
it's definitely much better queen h6
simply play queen e2 then long castle
this i don't see any any real real
compensation so they
so uh gary but still it's it was a
little fight it's don't the game game is
far from being over absolutely the last
time we talked was in paris a year ago
alireza was 2750 a huge prospect but he
hasn't confirmed yet at the top level
now he just exploded 2803
and but he hasn't played in five months
and he's ready to play in his first
candidates how would you assess alireza
as a player as well as his strategy
maybe not to play for five months before
the canvas
look um definitely i'm the last person
to criticize this decision because as a
betweening disciple so i always wanted
you know serious preparation and uh and
considering the fact that you know
that's the you know he's
he he might be the the real contender
for for the for
uh being the next challenger uh for the
world championship match um he wanted to
spend more time preparing
we'll see you know we'll see how he how
he does here in this tournament
uh microf5 was just played okay what do
we think of this movie
still again it's just you know he wants
to push the queen and and then just you
know too but after queen h7 i'm not so
sure you know that's the that he has
anything better than to get to go back
and now given that he has after nikola 5
15 minutes against 19 minutes do you
think he's going to repeat if we see
this on the board
i don't know understand
look it's i think don't forget but they
will play in in madrid so let's see
what makes this tournament even more
intriguing you have four players
that will go to madrid so it's alireza
yan uh um report
and fabian so that's why every game
between them it's just somehow rehearsal
so yesterday we saw um quite uneventful
game between fabian and and and alireza
so i think fabia had an advantage but he
didn't manage to actually get something
you know a real out of this advantage
but one interesting fact about it
yesterday they repeated the position
four times none of them wanted to claim
the draw maybe it's psychologically
psychological exactly yeah so yeah they
they are trying to position themselves
you know for for madrid
yeah absolutely absolutely so uh so
we're seeing this is yeah did he play he
played though
wow
you no no no no knight to f5 and right
now level is still thinking upon reading
his options but he has no i mean real
real options i mean says yes you cannot
queen g5 queen g4 so i guess this is a
big problem yeah and then queen of six
and then you go back yeah yeah
this gives white a clear advantage now
another crazy game uh is this one
between mamedyarov and richie report
now the position has come down come down
come down this is calm down compared to
what we have yeah exactly what is this
is the cold calm down
yeah i'm curious you don't say this is
the
way to go i see this computer office
bishop takes it bishop texas and bishop
divorce
yeah bishop
yes
yeah and the idea is to go but that's
the whatever you want
yeah it's like uh some sort of variation
yeah but this this is because you just
before and then you double up yeah
what takes
up you could have taken here probably
this is
you can take here
yeah but we'll see so it's this is how
much time left so 19 minutes for uh
richie and 12 minutes for mamedyaro it's
not the only move it seems like just
going backwards
now you have to go
let's see if he sees bishop h3 big
moment right now for uh luigi i bet he
would you think he i think he'll play
bishop takes history so it's the
uh yeah okay that's uh and this is
another extremely intriguing uh player
ritual report what is your assessment of
him he plays non-stop he says i don't
have any support i'm just going to
continue playing and do my best at the
candidates look he will
that's that's
that's a problematic problematic
attitude because you don't want to go to
candidates and to do to do your best
right you go there to win right or you
know just otherwise you can have fun
but you know it's i i i'm sure that uh
others attitude or fabi or even yan
they have a very different idea or or
young
so who by the way refused to to to play
in in in uh i guess um in grant's tour
exactly more time to prepare so
again as someone in there who just
learned from pavwinik i i appreciate is
this attitude so it's a risky one but
but you know it may work would you like
to take time for a preparation yeah it's
this is uh especially these days you
know when this year you can do a lot of
exercise playing you know just on online
but that's
we have you know we can definitely see
the different approach from magnus
i think it's it's it's very
it's it's quite unique strategy for each
player because it's very individual you
know yes something that works for me
more for carpool all the way around so
that you have to understand you know
this what what what's
what does work for you and uh
we'll see whether there is and and and
and and young christian though this is
they they made the right right calls
knowing yourself is uh definitely a huge
superpower now what about this game the
all-american clash
how do we how will we see this one
developing
i don't know it's just
it looks to me that it's it's it's
it's evil yeah probably is to just start
you know doubling
on d file but but he just
bit of pressure for white but not much a
little bit pressure but i
doubt that is anything serious
so um
maybe you could
i don't know just like rook f1 would be
one then somehow player four at one
point you probably have to play four if
you want to achieve anything but
i'm i'm
very skeptical about any any real
chances for this one i would say it's
from the draw gary
and we have we do have this last game uh
the one in which actually my last move
this move knight to e2 was made with two
seconds on the clock
yeah
but but but but but it's amazing you see
this
we look at this position it's just you
know why
yeah the one i had to take take here and
play with b2 that was a much better
chance yeah much better chances take on
d1 b2 and then after rook d3 there's if
e5 a5 yeah that's very strange that
level you know missed this chance and
levon at this point had 53 minutes on
the clock the rook c5 is he kept no more
pieces but you know but you see this is
h4 now he's just actually after e5 you
could take only five because the pawn is
no longer here and it's everything is
now protected yes so you see this is
yeah
yeah that's amazing stabilizing exactly
absolutely that will have rook h2 or
people rook h2o
and now
or maybe the advantage has slipped away
from uh absolutely yes
this one exactly very strange again
but
sometimes you look at the opponent's
clock instead of looking at the position
and i think this is exactly what he did
he played that move rook to c5 with two
only two minutes he spent on that gary
thank you very much for joining us and
we'll see you in the next few days i go
back to to to
to the main main main stage talking
about about geopolitics which is again
it's uh it's not ruled by uh
by people who respect the rules
absolutely thank you very much gary
appreciate it
thanks back to you thank you christian
and uh thank you gary